hey guys my name is Jess it is Tuesday
and we have slow news days here on GSM
use but this isn't one of them stay
tuned to find out what's going on if
you're still playing Pokemon girl you're
in for a treat come May 18 when the
Pokemon go adventure week event begins
at 1:00 p.m. on the 18th of May you'll
start seeing more rock-type pokémon
showing up in your augmented reality
including ammonite Aerodactyl onyx and
Kabuto as well as their evolved forms on
top of that the event adds more items to
focus tops
buddy Pokemon will receive candy after
walking a quarter of the normal required
distance and there's a new customization
option for your avatar called the
adventurers hat which all players get
for free if that all sounds good to you
you'll need to get going soon because
the event ends on May 25th at 1:00 p.m.
Pt a big destiny to event is coming this
week and while I'd usually advise
against telling you about news it's
going to happen in the future I can give
you some tips it's the first look at
just Anita's gameplay will be shown off
during a live stream on May 18 big day
while you're waiting Bungie posted the
first spongey podcast since 2014 it
features a chat between destiny to game
director Luke Smith and Project Lead
Marc newsworthy alongside community
manager Eric Osbourne one of the more
interesting takeaways is that destiny
two developers are playing the game in
its entirety at home on a private test
realm Smith said we're playing the [ __ ]
out of the game
Smith added I think it's a birth
basically like destiny to the baby is
going to be born either way it's coming
and so we're just going to need to get
to a place where we have to push he went
on to confirm he has no kids which might
explain the metaphor thankfully we don't
have to wait all the way until June to
find out about the big games that are on
the way as far cry 5 has been officially
confirmed Ubisoft confirmed the newest
entry in their open world first-person
wallet making simulator will be out
sometime
in the current fiscal year so before
March 31st 2018 unfortunately there are
no further details but will apparently
be learning more very soon which sounds
like a pretty three reveal to me
Ubisoft declined to address rumors
suggesting the game may be a Western so
yeah we really don't have much Ubisoft
changed their approach to major
franchises last year editorial VP Tommy
Francois said this is the goal we're
going for alpha one year before more
quality more polish so this means biting
the bullet and not having an assassin
this game or a far cry in 2017 pocket
we'll be updating you as soon as we have
any more info so make sure you subscribe
so you don't miss any of the details
that's everything I've got for you today
do let me know what you thought about
today's stories down in that comment box
and I will have more news feed tomorrow